Additionally, regarding substance tweeters, she believes that once that sweet taste hits
the tongue, the brain registers that and sends the signals to the pancreas to do its
thing.
Regardless of whether the sweeter is one that is metabolized or not, what do you think
of that process?
Yeah, I do know that that is a theory that the sweeter still affects a person because it's
dealing with the brain and not so much with the chemistry of the metabolism of the product.
So, but if, but understand the physiology there, so if that, what that can happen by eating
substance to sweeters, the, the, the danger that is you have an increase insulin production
and that could actually cause hypoglycemia. So, it wouldn't cause hyperglycemia. So, what
my curiosity abuse, what is your blood glucose level and how it is that you could test that
by, you know, checking your blood glucose level if you have a glucometer at home and you could eat
some substitute sweeters though, we're not talking about natural substance sweeters, we're
talking about like sugar alipahs, not like sucrams or something like that. And then you're,
or even stevia and see what it does to your blood sugar levels. Most likely it's not going
to change your blood sugar levels. So, you can look at that.
But, yeah, I do, you know, and there's, like I said, there's people that have issues with sugar
alcohols. And I think too many sugar alcohols are not good either. That was a huge thing with
Atkins diet was really big. We had people come in and they might lose weight on the Atkins diet,
but they ended up with too many sugar alcohols because that's just pretty much was the substitute
of the day in the bars and things like that and that could cause liver issues too.
A question came in. No problem with eating the fats. The CRP was very low like point one nine thought
that that was a good indicator of information. Yeah, your c-reactor protein is your one of your
main indications of inflammation also. Faratin can be an indicator of inflammation in the blood too.
But, but, as I can see our piece not going to be specific to anything, even though
there's another test called HSCRP which is high sensitivity CRP which says it's a little bit
more accurate to vascular inflammation. But it's none of them are going to be specific to
inflammation in the liver. If you had a change in the fats with that change in diet,
you still want to do some further investigation on your ability to digest those fats and your ability
to digest fats. You do have your pancreas does make my pace, which is an enzyme to digest fats,
but the majority of fat digestion is from the bile.
So, the bile is made in the liver, secreted into the bile duct into the gallbladder,
and then the bile gallbladder secreted into the first part of the smell attested when it senses
that there's fat there. Now, if a person has issues with the gallbladder which is very,
very common, more common in your female, then that could be part of the problem.
You don't want to overlook that. X-commit was also FYI. I didn't find any site that said
allulose was sugar alcohol. The one said it's not sugar alcohol but chemical structure similar to fluptose.
Oh, that's interesting. Okay. So, you could have a fluptose sensitivity. That's another possibility too.
So, that's really common. I used to work with 80-80-80-HD kids and spectrum kids.
The fluptose sensitivity was a huge problem with them. So, just because you have a diagnosis,
cancer doesn't mean you don't have other core morbidities. So...